I have a question what's that why given
every other possible option does a man
choose the life of a paid assassin well
it was that or the priesthood well are
you just the cutest thing he likes you
haha imagine that Ramsey a major stinky
face / boundaries this is my personal
bubble nah that ain't your bubble this
is not only know what I'm doing here
today I got out of plants in my life and
this wasn't part of it your father was
special take the truth I don't know if
this special only you're gonna know that
the time was right can angle it
overnight you wanna take a beer gonna
take this year to get knocked out you
gotta get up and you're gonna see if you
got the right thing but you got to work
hard I swear to God if you're not gonna
do it come on
you saw Peter didn't you
you tell him hi for me we're old friends
you know we had adjoining cells and the
capital for sure familiar with each
other's screams I'm going to kill snow
nothing good as safe while he's alive
and I can't make another speech about
now you're talking